[Music]
one foggy morning in 1884 the British
steamer Rumney
crashed into the French ship free
graphic seeing their ship filling with
water
the French crew climbed aboard the
Rumney but as they sailed toward the
nearest port a silent form suddenly
emerged from the fog the abandoned four
gora feet it was too late to turn and
the impact was enough to think the rum
me as the sailors scrambled into the
lifeboat the empty four gory seek sailed
back into the fog having seemingly taken
its revenge in reality the French
sailors had left the engines running and
the free gory Feig failed in a circle
before striking the Rumney
and finally sinking but his story became
one of the many tales of ghost ship
unmanned vessels that apparently sail
themselves and although they've
influenced works like Dracula and
Pirates of the Caribbean cruelest ships
aren't the product of ghostly spirits
just physics at work one of the most
famous ghost ships was the Mary Celeste
found sailing the Atlantic in 1872 with
no one aboard water in its hold and
lifeboats
missing the discovery of its intact
cargo and a captain's log that ended
abruptly led to wild rumors and
speculation but the real culprits were
two scientific phenomena buoyancy and
fluid dynamics here's how buoyancy works
an object placed in a liquid displaces a
certain volume of fluid the liquid in
turn exerts an upward buoyant force
equal to the weight of the fluid that's
been displaced this phenomenon is called
Archimedes principle objects that are
less dense than water such as salsa wood
icebergs and inflatable raft always flow
that's because the upward buoyant force
is always stronger than the downward
force of gravity but for objects or
ships to float when they're made of
materials like steel that are denser
than water
they must displace a volume of water
large
than their weight normally the water
filling a ship's hull would increase its
weight and caused it to sink just what
the Mary Celeste crew feared when they
abandoned ship but the sailors didn't
account for fluid dynamics the water
stopped flowing at the point of
equilibrium when it reached the same
level as the whole as it turned out the
weight of the water wasn't enough to
sink the ship and the Mary Celeste was
found a few days later while the
unfortunate crew never made it to shore
far stranger it's the tale of a Ernest
Mills a schooner transporting salt whose
crew watched it sink to the seafloor
following a collision yet four days
later it was spotted floating on the
surface the key to the mystery lay in
the ship's heavy cargo of salt the added
weight of the water in the hull made the
vessel sink but as the salt dissolved in
the water the weight decreased enough
that the force of gravity became less
than the buoyant force and the ship
floated back to the surface but how do
we explain the most enduring aspect of
ghost ship legends multiple sightings of
the same ships hundreds of miles and
several years apart the answer lies in
ocean currents which are like invisible
rivers flowing through the ocean factors
like temperature salinity wind gravity
and the Coriolis effect from the Earth's
rotation create a complex system of
water movement that applies both at the
ocean's surface and deep below sailors
have always known about currents but
their patterns work well known until
recently in fact tracking abandoned
ships was how scientists determines the
shape and speed of the Atlantic gyre the
Gulf Stream and related currents in the
first place beginning in 1883 the u.s.
hydrographic office began collecting
monthly data that included navigation
hazards like derelict ships whose
locations were reported by passing
vessels
so abandoned ship may not be moved by
ghost cruise or supernatural person but
they are a real and fascinating
phenomenon born through the ocean and
kept afloat by powerful invisible
scientifically studied forces
[Music]